Ned guess what what I have a surprise
what is it we're going wait where we
going
Cancun the greatest single destination
in the world yeah probably not so much
for a married person I'll be doing shots
all day I'll get you some hoes I'll be a
side feat no I mean look barely evil
cute by 11:00 what oh god we'll stay up
and watch the Sun Rise when do we go to
bed we don't vacations what what is a
married oh yes
healthy I'll take you on a vacation with
me and my wife
we'll go up to Napa we'll drive all
around the coast we'll look at all these
cute little wineries talk about like our
lives and how much we mean to each other
and like what is the future life will we
have children will we get a dog huit
well we got a dog a nice seafood dinner
then go back to a very fancy hotel room
and totally bone each other's brains out
and be in bed by 11:00 no thanks well I
will say one thing that I am jealous of
with going on vacation with the cost
between two people traveling with other
people is part of what makes it fun for
me that's why you get an international
data plan and use FaceTime [ __ ]
you're gonna FaceTime with your mom when
you're in like the Louvre yeah I did I
would feel lonely I guess yeah it's just
it's that's just a feeling I've become
accustomed to name is some place you've
always wanted to go one two three okay
oh yes what'd you do he gave them a
married friend yeah that has money and
then you go places together and then you
can still feel like you have a travel
buddy but and you don't have to you're
not married hey you don't have to have
sex with me unfortunately not everybody
is lucky tip to all those engaged
couples out there put in the notes we're
engaged and they might give me a free
upgrade I do it all the time even when I
travel by myself yeah when I want I also
bring the gate attendants little
Starbucks gift card whoo
$10 you get a $500 seat upgrade
apparently at hotels if you slip someone
a 20 when you're checking in yeah I
didn't know that until like very
recently he says that I wonder sometimes
how you've gotten this far where courage
pan I wanna go to Japan so bad
like I get nervous cuz the flight is so
long but I'm on everyone and that's an
extra really like wipe out a small
country yikes
[Music]